last year Jill Stein was carrying the
banner of the American left in the
presidential election she was the Green
Party candidate now she's been exposed
apparently despite leading the Green
Party she was a Russian spy all along
that's the claim believe it or not two
Senate committees are investigating her
as a possible crony of the Kremlin her
sins include appearing on RT that's the
Russian television channel Russia Today
and attending a dinner in 2015 where she
sat at the same table as Vladimir Putin
all of which makes her a modern Matahari
what does she say in her defense Jill
Stein joins us tonight dr. Stein thanks
for coming on great to be with you thank
you so much are you now or have you ever
been an agent of Russia do you speak
Russian how often do you talk to
Vladimir Putin like not at all like even
when briefly he sat at this head table
at a conference I was in Moscow for a
conference attended actually by the BBC
by the Canadian broadcast system by the
state TV networks for China India tell
us or etc this was a actual legitimate
conference it's all up on the web
there's nothing secret about it we were
posting information and putting out
press releases no backroom deals no
secret meetings in oligarchy towers or
anything like that all very transparent
in public the dinner at the end of the
conference was really a non-event at one
point Putin came in with a couple of
guys that I assumed were his bodyguards
turns out they were actually his inner
circle but you would have never known it
nobody was introduced to anybody there
was no translator actually no not a word
exchanged at one point Putin made a very
rapid turn around the table and shook
everybody's hand but without any
exchange of names so that's about as
significant as this was in collusion to
me so wait
we get to a real crime which was running
for president as a third party candidate
and in the view of a lot of people in
Washington you got Donald Trump elected
do you see this as punishment for the
crime of running president yes yes I
mean in many ways many of the articles
like the New York Times three days ago
in announcing this investigation began
with a quote from a former spokesperson
for the Clinton campaign saying that
well isn't this great because so many
Clinton Democrats are furious at me
they're outraged that I dared in so many
words
you know dared to think that we get to
make up our own minds that our votes
don't belong to Hillary Clinton or to
anybody else but I got to say you know
it's not just Democrats this is a
bipartisan Commission we know led by
Republicans I'm aware and yeah yeah they
have it in as well because it's very
inconvenient to have a you know an
opposition political party that's not
disagree with you look if they disagree
with what you're saying for the record I
disagree with almost everything you say
but if you disagree with what you say
why not argue against it why try to
pretend that you're an agent of a
foreign government that seems like
McCarthyism to me you know you're not
the only person to suggest that I think
you know this is you know let me say I
think there are legitimate aims here in
the investigation I think an
interference in our election is much
bigger than the Russians you know and we
have yet to see the proof I would like
to see the evidence of Russian
culpability here when John Kennedy you
know was facing the Cuban Missile Crisis
he Declassified the evidence to show the
photographs of the missiles in Cuba all
right you know aren't we oh dad is the
American public we didn't get to really
see the evidence before the run-up to
the Iraq war we are still paying that
price five and a half trillion dollars
and Counting you know fool me once shame
on you fool me a gazillion times shame
on all of us well so I limit let me
revise what I said I actually do agree
with you on something and I strongly
agree with you in that Jill Stein good
luck I hope you get that done and good
luck on the hill thank you thank you so
much take care